au musée national de l'île vivent le
temps s'est arrêté
il n'y a plus que le bruit des pas de
son directeur qui résonne et l'écho
lointain de la guerre tous les tableaux
ont été retirés le musée a perdu son âme
ce que nous avons fait il ya un mois
était douloureux confie le directeur des
centaines de tableaux de gravure et de
sculptures ont été retirés soigneusement
emballés et caché secrètement aux quatre
coins de la ville parfois sous terre
l'opération au monumental a pris dix
jours
causant se fait un devoir de protéger le
patrimoine de son pays une possible
attaque russe
dans ce musée nous avons des pièces
uniques qui n'ont pas de prix
l'institution est reconnu pour son
imposante collection patrimoniale des
icônes médiévales des gravures
folkloriques et des manuscrits anciens
ici se trouve est unique on du 15e
siècle et your connais par coeur la
place qu'occupait chaque oeuvre est très
sport si une pièce devait disparaître ou
si petite soit elle ce serait une perte
non seulement pour l'ukraine mais aussi
pour la culture du monde entier
à quelques kilomètres de là des sirènes
d'alert interrompre constamment les
cours de l'académie nationale des arts
mais les étudiants ici reste déterminé à
garder la création bien vivante les
couleurs de l'oeuvre de katia sont aussi
vives que ses émotions
cette silhouette orange incarne la
douleur une autre symbolisera le combat
la guerre aussi déchirantes soit elle
est devenue une source d'inspiration
je suis triste mais mon désir de créer
est plus fort que jamais dit elle
il faut donner un souffle nouveau à la
culture quoi cet autre étudiante
l'art est une preuve que nous existons
explique cela alors que les russes dont
de nous détruire
nous ne nous sommes jamais sentis ou
s'il craignait que depuis le début de la
guerre
dior lui se demande quand il pourra
accrocher ses tableaux à nouveau nom
bref cet accord social
avec un voisin comme le nôtre a dit il
c'est difficile à prévoir il est
impatient de revoir ses oeuvres mais
aussi d'accueillir le public à nouveau
mozer basile audet pour exister le musée
a besoin de ses oeuvres et de ses
visiteurs
sans eux il est comme un entrepôt dit il
[Musique]
avant de quitter l'édifice notre
interprète ukrainien il a a décidé de
combler le vide à sa manière
[Musique]
ici louisbourg et radio canada
à